quand on songe faire affaire avec un
nouveau patron qui s'annonce difficile
mieux vous prouver sans retard qu'on
peut lui apporter des solutions
si le principe qui semblait guider lundi
les premiers pas de danse de justin
trudeau à washington avec l'éléphant
amérique avant toute autre déclaration
les deux leaders ont annoncé la création
conjointe d'un conseil canadien
américain sur l'avancement des femmes
d'affaires et entrepreneurs
[Musique]
officiellement cette initiative vise à
favoriser la croissance des entreprises
appartenant à des femmes de manière à ce
qu'elles contribuent à la croissance
économique la concurrence et à
l'intégration des deux économies
officieusement elle permet à justin
trudeau de montrer qu'il a amené à
washington dans ses valises un peu de
cet esprit des valeurs chères aux
canadiens pour trempe
cela permet de commencer à rebâtir son
image troué par des propos misogynes en
rafale
en somme une opération quelque peu sur
elle il faudrait bien lisez et
professeur de droit et de relations
internationales à l'université brock à
sainte-catherine tout près de toronto en
août soit canadien qui souvent très très
opposés aux préfectures alors trudeau
devait dire d'un côté quatre ans oui on
est avec vous on était un allié très
serré des états unis mais en même temps
de venir au canada t on
on est en train de défendre les valeurs
canadiennes les positions canadiens sont
souvent très divergentes face aux
positions américaines
et ça ça voulait dire essentiellement
parler de certaines choses me trouver un
équilibre avec les choses qu'on devait à
dire à la l'administration trump ou les
parler économie et sécurité
trudeau vous voulez parler de ces
questions là aussi me trudeau a esquivé
toutes les autres questions sur
lesquelles il ya des différends très
très prononcé face à la mutation preuve
par l implication de l'environnement
trudeau a parlé pendant toute sa
campagne électorale de l'environnement
et vous disposez comme protecteur
d'environnement et et son administration
se fiche complètement des questions
environnementales alors trudeau encore
une fois devez trouver un équilibre là
aussi et puis on va parler de ce simon
va pas parler de ça on peut faire
semblant que les problèmes n'existent
pas mais par rapport à l'alena
la question a été abordée de front alors
que le président trump a annoncé que
il y avait renégociation de l'accord
notamment entre le canada et les états
unis
cette obligation se ferait à petite
échelle aurait rien à voir avec le type
de renégociation que les états unis
veulent pas voir avec le mexique
oui avait c'est un peu ce qu'avait dit
le principal consignes monsieur trump
monsieur trudeau lorsqu'il avait fait
100 réunion du conseil des ministres il
patricia carli où il avait dit ne soyez
pas inquiet concernant les notre point
d'interrogation est davantage avec le
mexique avec le canada gérard deltell
est un député et porte parole
conservateur canadien en matière de
finance donc monsieur doit on peut
répéter un peu ce que c était ce que ses
conseillers avait dit mais ça nous
inquiète dans la mesure où ne pas
toucher directement les enjeux qui
peuvent porter à controverse
que ce soit la question du protoss que
ce soit la question de la gestion de
l'offre ou autres enjeux qui nous touche
directement canada les etats unis c'est
notre principal partenaire mais
également notre principal compétiteur
alors oui c'est quand même bien pensée
on leur connaît tous et en mai mais on
est quand même encore beaucoup intrigué
ou enfin concernés par le fait que sur
les enjeux principaux qui nous sépare il
a pas eu d'avancée les intérêts
économiques sont si importants entre les
deux pays qu' il ya une réalité
économique qui je pense rattraper tout
le monde fait de rites boily et
politicologue ou campus saint-jean de
l'université de l'alberta dans l'ouest
du pays
bondues certain que sur le plan de
philosophie politique monsieur trudeau
reste encore en désaccord avec monsieur
30 mai c'est à paul moment délit est
allée des différences certains
journalistes lui ont tendu des perches
mais monsieur trudeau n'a pas mordu à
l'hameçon de même que monsieur tron
moment donné il ya eu des questions
monsieur tron aurait pu être disons plus
montrer davantage cédé à caen mais non
je pense que dans ce contexte lol et la
rencontre a été plutôt réussie l'ex
ministre des finances du québec raymond
bachand qui va agir comme conseiller
spécial du gouvernement du québec lors
des négociations sur la nena affirme que
ce rapprochement sur la question de la
lena est très important puisque la
renégociation de cet accord économique
et le plus grand enjeu
selon lui depuis les 20 dernières années
pour la province du québec
les productions spéciales
un reportage de radio canada
international